das wollen wir jetzt wissen von
Professorin Veronika Grimm sie ist
Mitglied im Sachverständigenrat der
Bundesregierung also eine der
Wirtschaftsweisen und eine der
Energieexpertin des Landes einen schönen
guten Morgen nach Nürnberg
guten Morgen also zwei Atomkraftwerke
Frau Grimm bleiben als Notreserve am
Netz reicht das um die Stromversorgung
in Deutschland in dieser Krisensituation
zu sichern reicht das damit wir sicher
durch den Winter kommen
ja das ist eine sehr überraschende
Entscheidung finde ich vor allen Dingen
weil wir auf diese Art ja die Kosten
haben die Kraftwerke zu verlängern also
man muss den Betreibern eine angemessene
Entschädigung zahlen das wurde ja auch
so gesagt aber wir haben gar nicht den
Nutzen nämlich dass sie billigen Strom
produzieren der ja dazu beitragen würde
dass die Strompreise auch niedrig
bleiben und vor allen Dingen was dazu
beitragen würde dass auch die Futures
also die zukünftigen Strompreise niedrig
bleiben und da hätte man glaube ich über
die reine Versorgungssicherheit hinaus
denken müssen und überlegen können und
sollen welche Rolle können die
Atomkraftwerke spielen mit Blick auf
diese energiepreiskrise auch die wir ja
haben die ja auch das Entlastungspaket
umfangreich adressieren soll lassen Sie
mich dann noch mal nachfragen eignen
sich denn Atomkraftwerke überhaupt als
Reservekraftwerke für den schnellen
Einsatz bei plötzlichem Strommangel denn
es dauert ja ungefähr eine Woche die
Reaktoren wieder hochzufahren
ja als Betriebsbereitschaft einigen
eignen sie sich eben sehr schlecht weil
sie eben nicht unmittelbar wieder
hochgefahren werden können wie das Gas
bei Gaskraftwerken der Fall wäre es wäre
jetzt im Fall der Atomkraftwerke sind
voll sie noch eine Weile laufen zu
lassen um eben die Preise abzufedern je
mehr Kraftwerkskapazität zur Verfügung
steht dass du niedriger sind ja die
Strompreise weil der Preis ergibt sich
im Zusammenspiel aus Angebot und
Nachfrage darüber hinaus hätte man
natürlich auch überlegen können die
Laufzeit zu verlängern weil die
energiepreiskrise die ist ja nicht in
drei vier Monaten vorbei das wird sich
sicherlich noch eine Weile hinziehen das
fordert ja auch gerade der FDP
Finanzminister Lindner die
Atomkraftwerke die drei verbliebenen
noch bis 2024 weiterlaufen zu lassen was
würden Sie denn generell sagen was jetzt
zu tun ist in dieser Krise wie wir in
Sachen Energie jetzt gut durch diesen
Herbst und Winter kommen
ja die erste Priorität muss sein so viel
Strom Angebot zu schaffen die möglich
also die aktuell verfügbaren Kraftwerke
die Strom produzieren können an den
Markt zu bringen das sind
Kohlekraftwerke die reaktiviert werden
aber das sind eben auch die
Atomkraftwerke die aktuell Strom
produzieren können das würde dazu führen
dass die sogenannte mered Order über die
jetzt viel diskutiert wird nach außen
geschoben wird und der Strompreis eben
niedriger würde den Strompreis künstlich
zu drücken indem man in staatlich
deckelt und irgendwie kompensiert das
ist viel umständlich und da ist
überhaupt nicht gesagt ob das so gut
funktioniert und ob das auch so einfach
realisierbar ist also Stromangebot
schaffen wäre eigentlich das Gebot der
Stunde und insofern sollte man eben die
Kraftwerke an den Markt bringen die
Kohlekraftwerke da ist in das Problem
dass die Versorgung mit Kohle gar nicht
so einfach sich als sich herausstellt
wie man das ursprünglich dachte und
deswegen ist es eben wichtig eigentlich
über alle Möglichkeiten nachzudenken
schauen wir noch mal kurz auf die
Maßnahmen der Bundesregierung für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die Regierung hat
gerade das dritte Entlastungspaket auf
den Weg gebracht neben lob gibt es auch
Kritik unter anderem vom Mittelstand und
dem Handwerk wie sehr leiden die denn
unter den steigenden Gas und
Strompreisen
massiv das die Unternehmen leiden jetzt
natürlich genauso wie die Haushalte
massiv unter steigenden Strompreisen bei
den Unternehmen kommen die steigenden
Preise auch viel schneller an als bei
den Haushalten weil bei den Haushalten
ja aufgrund von längeren
Vertragslaufzeiten erst Stück für Stück
die hohen Preise tatsächlich beim
Verbraucher ankommen und ich glaube da
ist jetzt Sorge zu tragen dafür dass
eben die Unternehmen schnell niedrigere
Strompreise erfahren der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien hilft hier eher
mittelfristig weil eben die erneuerbaren
Energieanlagen erst gebaut werden müssen
und insofern müssen wir in den sauren
Apfel beißen und hier konventionelle
Kraftwerke die entweder klimaschädlich
sind oder eben auf Kernenergie basieren
müssten wir eigentlich länger laufen
lassen jetzt um eben diese Krise
unmittelbar zu adressieren Einschätzung
waren das von der Wirtschaftsweisen und
Energie-
ich danke Ihnen